what we're going to do in this video is
to start thinking about adding mixed
numbers now just as a reminder what a
mixed number is it'd be something like 3
and 2 8. it's called mixed because part
of the way we represent this number is
as a whole number the 3 and then part is
as a fraction 2 8 but the number is 3
and 2 8. so let's think about how we
might be able to add 3 and 2 8
2
5
five
and
three eighths
so pause this video and see if you can
if you can have a go at this before we
work through this together
all right now let's work through this
together now there's a couple of ways
that we could approach this
you might recognize that three and
two-eighths is the same thing as three
plus two-eighths
and five and three-eighths is the same
thing as
five
plus
8 and so if we add these two things
together we're just adding really these
four things together
and the order in which we add doesn't
matter so you could view this as
three
plus five
plus
2 8
plus 2 8
plus 3 8.
notice it's just the same thing i'm just
changing the order with which we are
adding and now what is 3
plus five three wholes plus five wholes
well that's just going to be eight
and then what is two-eighths plus
three-eighths
well if i have two of something in this
case eights and i add three more of that
something in this case 8 i'm going to
have 5 of that something in this case 5
8. so this is going to be 8 plus
5 8 which we can express as a mixed
number as just being equal to
8
and
5
8.
now there's other ways that you might
see folks approaching this you might see
something like this where people will
write
3
plus
2 8
and then they will write right below
that they'll write the five in the ones
place or in the whole number and there's
only a ones placed in these holes in
these whole numbers so you'd write the 5
right below the 3 and then plus and then
the fraction you'd write right below the
fraction
3 8
and then we can
add vertically like this where first we
can look at the fractional part 2 8 plus
3 8
is going to be equal to
5 8 and then 3 plus 5
is going to be equal to 8 and if you add
these two together 8 and 5 8 you get 8
and 5 8. so different ways to approach
it but that will hopefully start to get
you comfortable with adding mixed
numbers